こんにちははじめ社長です梅雨が明けたということでねちょっと久しぶりに晴れなので
今日はちょっと文の方に来てますで今日はそんなねこちらのなんだっていうですねあの
子供立使う今日みたいにあるんですけどそうプールスティックを10本今日は買ってき
ましたっっ今日50本買ってきたのですっ
もうフル説教50本を買ってきたので今日はこちらのプーステップ50本1丁こちらの
プールスティック50本使ってあの日の海がすぐそこにあるね
その海ねプールスティック50本体に身につけてやぶぅ燻製を好きやみてねかなり霞ん
でゆくので体中につけて今の今日は今今日はじゃないよ今日は形にぷるー
てくっつけてもうこの人間の体のままねじゃあ海で不幸と思います
とりあえず浮きたいのよ
ではいかんよ4月ます
は付けないから
そうこれはいいやばいやばい注意気しかせない
みんな中国スクールシャアで完成
は4差足をか長くしてるようなもんですねあしら言葉でしょ
ああ
ええええっはっはっは
乳首をすくい上げるとかっ
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおいっ
dee
ime
なーんかが出来ましたというわけださて今年が
ni
ani
ミニあげるからねます
強くなってきちゃうやつっもっ